[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم الى هذه الحلقه الجديده من
برنامج من المصدر المهتم بتحليل المشهد
الاعلامي العربي والدولي ثلاثه مواضيع
استوقفتنا هذا الاسبوع
هل انتهى وقته ام ان الفضيحه اكبر من ان
يتم تجاهلها
نصر الله
حكم المعلقين الكاتب الصحفي طارق الحميد
ضيفنا اليوم للحديث عن تصيح زعيم
اغلقوا قناه روسيا اليوم الفرانكو فنيه يا
جوجو بفرنسا في لائحه مقوي حريه التعبير
وفق السلطات الروسيه فما تبريرها
[موسيقى]
موضوعنا الاول من امريكا حيث يشتعلوا
الاعلام على وقع تكشف المزيد من الوثائق
الحكوميه السريه بحوزه الرئيس
الرئاسه ازمه يتفاقم حجمها كره الثلج ولا
يبدو انها ستتلاشى قريبا مع تشبيهها في
الاعلام الامريكيه بقضيه تركيه تلك القضيه
التي اطاحت بالرئيس السابق ريتشاردن التي
على اثرها اقره قانون يلزم رؤساء ونوابهم
بتسليم كامل الوثائق المتصله بعملهم
للارشيف الوطنيه
[موسيقى]
غرفه غرفه
المكتب والاعلامي للبيت الابيض تلقى سهام
المنتقدين بشكل مباشر رغم تبريره بان
الرئيس هو من اخبر الجهات المختصه
بالمستندات بعد ان اكتشف انها بحوزته
وتعود الى فتره توليه منصب نائب الرئيس
الاسبق وفتره عمله في مجلس الشيوخ
والمتحدثه باسم البيت الابيض كان لها
النصيب الاكبر من الانتقادات المباشره من
قبل مراسل البيت الابيض الذين حاصروها
باسئلتهم كيف لا وهي التي نفت امامهم
بوجود مستندات سرديه اخرى في منزل الرئيس
الخاص قبل ان يعلن القضاء عثوره على ملفات
جديده بعد 48 ساعه من النافيه
انا
متحدثته
بالاسوا على الاطلاق منذ اختراع التلفاز
حيث انها لا تستطيع الاجابه على ابسط
اسئله الصحفيه
من جديد لطورطهما في نفس القضيه اعلام
الجمهوريين يبرر الكون الوثائق التي كانت
بحوزه شم كان قد ازال عنها السريه قبل
نهايه بموجات صلاحياته اما الديمقراطيون
فيرون ان بيض تعاون بشكل كامل مع قضاء
لتسليم الوثائق ولكن من دون تبرير خطائه
بطبيعه الحال الجمهوريون يستغلون الفرصه
الى اقصى الحدود منتقدين ازدواجيه
المعايير في الطاعات الاعلامي للقضيه
لكنهم يرون ان الطاعات الاعلام المقرب من
الرئيس مفتعل ويحمل ابعادا اخرى بلغم ان
محامي بايد ان اكتشفوا الوثائق منذ الثاني
من نوفمبر اي عشيه الانتخابات النصفيه الا
انها لم تظهر للاعلام الا في التاسع من
يناير عندما ذكرت قناه سي بي اس الاخباريه
ان المحامين الشخصيين لدى رئيس اكتشفوا
وثائق سرديه في مكتبه قبل اكثر من شهرين
والبيت الابيض وقتها اكدابا وكان لافتان
اتفاق البعض في فوكس نيوز المقربه من
الجمهوريين بان غضب اعلام الديمقراطيين
مصطلح لانه هناك تحديات اكبر تهدد امريكا
تدفق المهاجرين وارتفاع نسب الجرائم من
حسنه المستندات السرديه التي سلمها الرئيس
احتمال
انت هبل القضيه
اهلا بك جيلان من واشنطن الماطره طبعا حيث
اقف انا بجواري هناك ايضا صيانه فوكس ام
بي سي ام بي سي كل المحطات الامريكيه التي
تراقب حركات الرئيس
وتترقب كل بيان يصدر من كريم جون بير
لكنها بدات محاصره في الاسابيع السابقه
بسبب قضيه الوثائق طبعا البيت الابيض يتهم
بعدم الشفافيه باخفاء بعض المعلومات رغم
انه قال بانه تعاون مع المحققين ومكتبه
تحقيق الفيدرالي هو بان قضيه الرئيس بايرن
تختلف تماما عن الرئيس ترامب الذي لم
يتعاون وذهب الى حد ان يتم اقتحام بيته او
منتهي في مراره لارجو لكن الكشف عن وثائق
ايضا جديده في بيت مايك برنس
كشف عنها في ولايه انديانا اعطت بعض
الهامش للرئيس لي والبيت الابيض للتحرك
والقول باننا
هو بنستعاوناه مع طبعا مكتب التحقيق
الفيدرالي وزاره العدل وسلم- كل هذه
الوثائق الى السجل الوطني او النشر الارض
كايد وبالتالي هم مختلفين تماما عن قضيه
الرئيس ترامب الذي يواجه تحقيقا رسميا لكن
على كل الاحوال قد تؤثر هذه الوثائق
وفضيحه الوثائق اذا اردنا وصفها على ربما
ترشح الرئيس الذي ننتظرهما بعد حال خطاب
حال الاتحاد هناك تحدي له من قبل بعض
الديمقراطيين الذين قالوا بان كان على
البيت الابيض ان يتعامل بشكل مختلف وان
هذا اهمال من قبل الرئيس الذي قال بانه
يتعامل مع هذه الوثائق بشكل جدي جدا لكن
هناك طبعا همم محاولات من قبل البعض لوضع
الرؤساء السابقين طبعا الرئيس السابق
دونالد ترامب والرئيس الحالي همم نائب
الرئيس السابق
خالد بانهم لا يتمتعون بالصلاحيه وهم غير
مخولين بان يترشحوا للرئاسه القادمه في
عام 20 24
بوتين الغاره في وحل الحرب الاوكرانيه
لماذا غابت هذا العام صوره غطسته الجليديه
السنويه الاعلام الغربي يدقق بالموضوع
التفاصيل بعد الفاصل
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد مقال الاسبوع اخترناه
للكاتب السعودي طارق الحميد ذلك لان
المقال يلخص المشاديه التي تضغط على
الاعلام العربيه هذا الاسبوع بعد ان ظهر
امين عام حزب الله بمظهر المستغيث بدول
الخليل لتقديم العون الاقتصادي هو يتحدث
عن الخطبه نصر الله غمزه من قناه الانفاق
على الصفقات الرياضيه في معرض طلبه
للمساعدات الخليجيه ولكن لن نضع جانبا كل
السيارات والملاحظ فقط ليست لديه اي فكره
عن العالم الاستثمار الرياضيه هذا لانه
ربما الاقتصاد الذي يديره يقوم على مقومات
اخرى فالتهامات لحزب الله بالتجاره
والمخدرات والاسلحه وغسيل الاموال وغيرها
من الانشطه غير المشروعه لا تتوقف هذا في
وقت كانت السعوديه تحتفل بصراتها الجديده
مع اهم نجوم العالم كرويا وفنيا وثقافيا
من خلال فعاليات موسم الرياضه التي جذب
اهتمام الاعلام الدولي وزير الماليه
السعودي شرح لقناه سي ام بي سي الامريكيه
فوائد استقطاب النجوم الى السعوديه وتابعه
ذلك اقتصاديا
يفز فيجن
دوت كوم
اذا جوده الحياه تدخل في صوب سياسه
الاستقطاب الرياضيين التي هي جزء من رؤيه
المملكه 2030 التي تستهدف تنويع مصادر
الدخل وتحسين حياه المواطنين بكافه
اشكالهم والنتائج بدات تظهر مع ارتفاع
الناتج المحلي الى 8% هذا العام طبعا هذه
الامور لا تعني نصر الله المنشغل فقط
بتعزيز سيطره للشيخ حزب الله على لبنان
وزعزع استقرار دول العربيه لصالح ايضا
فيما يطلب العون الخليجي لا يتراجع عن
مشروعه تدمر للسعوديه ودول الخليج والذي
وصفه ذات مره باشرف الجهاد وفقات تعبير
افضل شيء عملته بحياتك اعظم شيء عملته
بحياتك بقول لك هو الخطاب اللي على القلب
القيته ثاني يوم من الحوض السعوديه على
اليمن واللي عم يعملها
وبسعر انه هيدا هو الجهاد الحقيقي
وتحديدا السعوديه لا تزال تعيش مرحله
المزايدات او التاثر بالخطاب الشعبي كما
قال الكاتب الصحفي طارق الحميد في مقاله
في الشرق الاوسط وما لا يستوعبه نصر الله
وامثاله انه نعم كره القدم اهم لانها تعني
ان هناك منظومه متكامله اقتصاديا وسياسيا
واجتماعيا
تعملوا من اجل المواطن والوطن منظومه حياه
وعمل واستثمار ورفاهيه لا منظومه التخلف
كما يفعل نصر الله واتباع ايران وفقا
الكاتب
ومن الرياض ينضم الينا كاتب المقال طارق
الحميد طبعا سال الكثير من الحبر عن طلب
نصر الله اللافت كيف تقرا توقيته وهل من
الصعب الاستجابه له طبعا مقالك الاخير اخذ
جدل واسع داخل لبنان وخارج لبنان هل لك ان
تشرح لنا توقيت استغاثه نصر الله للسعوديه
بهذا التوقيت بالذات وهل يمكن ان يستجاب
له
اول شيء اهلا وسهلا بك
مع حضرتك في هذا البرنامج المميز الامر
الاخر انا اعتقد ان ما قاله حسن نصر الله
لم يكن متطلب او طلب هو كان هناكفه وعمليه
شيء انا وعمليه رفع ال- همم الاعباء
الخروج من دائره الضغوط في لبنان لتحميلها
لطرف اخر وهو السعوديه هذه العمليه ليست
جديده هذه العمليه تقريبا من 2006 وما قبل
2006 ولكن اكثر حده في 2006 تحميل
السعوديه دائما اعباء مواقف حزب الله
واعبا مواقفهم الخاطئه ومغامراتهم هناك هو
يتحدث للتاليبه ويتحدث للشيطان وهو يتحدث
لاتباعه ويتحدث لتاليب اللبنانيين هل يمكن
الاستجابه لمطالبه لا يمكن الاستجابه
لمطالبه لانه حسن نصر الله كان يستطيع ان
يقدم للبنان دون ان يدفع دولار واحد مواقف
افضل من 300 مليار او 400 مليار مثل ما
ذكرت في مقالي وهي ان يمرر او يسهل عمليه
اختيار الرئيس المتفق عليه في لبنان راس
الوزاره ناجحين سيرى الاستثمار حينها سيرى
السياح والعالم تاتي هذا امر الامر الاخر
السعوديه اعلنت على لسان وزير خارجيتها في
منتدادافس على لسان وزير ماليتها في منتدى
دافوس بان المملكه لن تتبرع للتبرع
المملكه تريد وتطالب الدول الاخرى بالقيام
باصلاح مثل ما قامت المملكه بنفسها باصلاح
ثم نبحث عن فرص للشراكه خليني اقول لك
معلومه ما قد قلتها او لم اكتبها من قبل
سالت مسؤول سعودي عن لبنان قلت له اشرح لي
بلغه بسيطه جدا اين نحن ذاهبون مع لبنان
ما هي النقطه التي سنصل لها لنتبرع للبنان
او نساعد لبنان ماديا قال لي تجاوزنا هذه
المرحله يجب ان تكون هناك شراكه يجب ان
تكون هناك بنود ولكن ساقول لك شيء قلت
تفضل قال لي انا لدي مبلغ من المال وانت
لديك مبلغ من المال انت لبناني ملياراتك
اموالك تودعها في الخارج وتطالبني انا ان
اودع اموالي في لبنان لمساعده لبنان ما
رايك ان تاتي بام انت اللبناني وانا اتي
باموال للاستثمار اعتقد اللقطه واضحه
للمشاهده هنا اذا كان بعض الشخصيات في
لبنان تهرب بامولها للخارج كيف ستطالب دول
الخليج او المملكه العربيه السعوديه بان
تاتي الى لبنان للاستثمار هذه هذه اجابتها
على سؤال حضرتك
بكل تاكيد بكل تاكيد سيكون هناك شروط لا
اعتقد ان السعوديه اعلنت موقف رسمي انه كل
ما هو في مصلحه المواطن اللبناني لن تمسه
الانتظره من وديعه او غيره ولكن التبرع
بالطريقه التي يطالب بها بهذا الشكل غير
وارده ولا اعتقد بعدين في نقطه اخرى
استاذتي الفاضله في 2016 تقريبا خرج حسن
نصر الله مفاخرا بين موازنته رواتبه
واسلحه امواله كلها تاتي من ايران ولا
يريد من احد شيئ يتكلم عن المملكه العربيه
هذه الاموال
انا اعتقد لو كان هو حريص على اللبنانيين
وعلى الدوله اللبنانيه لكان استطاع ان
يقدم حل دون ان يدفع دولار واحد ولكن هذه
مناكفه وتحليب ومحاوله شيطان
حسبي الله انا مثل ما قلت في مقالي وقدمت
له نصيحه تحدثنا عن تمرير الرئيس تحدثنا
عن تمرير رئاسه الوزراء حزب الله لن اتحدث
في شان السلاح هذا شان لبناني لكن لو قال
حزب الله انا تحت مظله الدوله انا هنا فقط
للدفاع عن الدوله اللبنانيه لن اتدخل بامر
اخر يعني المشكله تقريبا على الطريقه
اللبنانيه فيها تدوير زوايا لكنه غير قابل
للحل سيده الفاضله نحن امام مسلمين او
موسمات موسم الرياض استثمار ترفيه جوده
حياه النتائج منظومه اقتصاديه متكامله
ولدينا موسم القتل في ايران ما يريده حسن
نصر الله ان نتعاون معه في موسم القتل
اعتقد المملكه العربيه السعوديه ودول
الخليج وكل عاقل في العالم العربي يريد ان
يشارك في موسم الرياض وليس موسم القتل في
ايران هذا ما لم يستوعبه حسن نصر الله لن
يستوعبه ولا يستطيع يعني
لبنان الحكومه اللبنانيه يقوم بها الاطراف
في لبنان اليوم مثلا سيدتي الفاضله
الفرنسيين باتوا اقرب للموقف السعودي من
قبل التصريحات الاعلاميه فيها كثير من
الدبلوماسيه بين السعوديه وفرنسا ولكن ما
يقال في الغرفه المغلقه الان من قبل
الفرنسيين للسعوديه ان تقييمكم كان صادق
وجاءت في لبنان
لخصت الموضوع بطريقه شامله وافيه الكاتب
الصحفي السعودي استاذ طارق الحمايه شكرا
جزيلا لمشاركتك معنا في منستر شكرا
شكرا لك شكرا لك
[موسيقى]
وفي فقره التحديات الاعلاميه تواجه روسيا
حظرا اعلاميا جديدا في اوروبا وتحديدا في
فرنسا بعد ان اعلنت سلطات هناك تجميد
حسابات قناه ارتي الفرنسيه المتفرعه من
قناه ارتي الروسيه المحظوره في الاتحاد
الاوروبي القرار الفرنسي الاخير ادى الى
اغلاق مكاتبها في باريس بسبب تعذر دفع
رواتب الموظفين وتامين مدفوعات المحطه
اوضح ان هذا القرار الفرنسي جاء التطبيقا
لحزمه عقبات الاوروبيه جديده استهدفت
تجميد اصول كيانات محدده من ضمنها ار تي
لمنعها من انتاج اعمالها بعد ما تم حظر
بثها في مارس الماضي
بمنع الانتاج المحتوى المحطه جاء مكملا
لقرار حظر البث
شو وضعت الخطوه في اطار اسقاط
التروباكاندر روسيه وفقد صحيفه بوتين
يستخدم القناه لبث الانشقاق داخل اوروبا
والترويجي غير الشرعيه ضد اوكرانيا وفقا
الصحيحه
في المقابل اشارت قناه ارتي في بيانها الى
ان الاتحاد الاوروبي تذرع بالموضوع في
اوكرانيا
المتوازنه للاحداث وذكرت اداره القناه بما
وصفته بالاستهدافات المتكرره التي تعرضت
لها منذ انطلاقتها مؤكده ان الضغوط عليها
ناتجه عن قرارات سياسيه وذكر البيان ايضا
ان الصمت المطلق لوسائل الاعلام سينمهد
الطريق لخطوات تطال وسائل الاعلام اخرى لا
تروق للسلطات فهل تثبت فرنسا مره اخرى ان
شعارات التعدديه وحريه الراي والتعبير لم
يعد لها مكان في فرنسا
سؤال نتوجه به الى محمد سيف الدين من
فرنسا الباحث في العلاقات الدوليه
والمتخصص في الشان الروسي استاذ لم نرى
تنديدا من الوسائل الاعلام الفرنسيه على
القرار الذي يعتبره البعض انه يقود حريه
التعبير كيف تفسر ذلك في البلد الذي يحترم
بالعاده حريه التعبير
الروسي يبوس من فرنسا
التي اقفلت الان او اقفلت حساباتها الان
لكن مساله التضامن الاعلامي الفرنسي مع
هذه القناه او مع ال- ال- الخطاب الاعلامي
الروسي او مع الحريات باتجاه الاعلام
الروسي نعم لم تكن ملحوظه واعتقد ان هذا
مرتبط بالسياق الاحداث الان وتطورها الى
الى مكان حيث يعني همم وصلت التوتر واعتقد
ان فرنسا الان ذهبت خطوه اضافيه باتجاه
الموقف الموحد لان انتم همم بقياده
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وبالتالي همم
هي مفارقه كبيره جدا ان لا يقوم الاع
الفرنسي بالحديث عن الحريات واعتقد ان كل
المعطيات التي يبثها الاعلام الروسي خصوصا
حول مصير المساعدات الغربيه الى اوكرانيا
يمكن ان يدور بهذا او يؤدي الى تاجيج هذه
الاحتجاجات وهذا مرتبط بالداخل الفرنسي
روسيا تقول ان ان هذا القرار يثبت مره
اخرى ان شعارات التعدديه وحريه التعبير لا
مكان لها في فرنسا ما ردواك نعم اعتقد ان
سياق المواجهه ايضا مره اخرى هو الذي يعني
حتى على هذه الدول في الغرب بان تاخذ
موقفا كاملا وحاده بهذا بهذا السياق ولا
اعتقد ان انه كان يجب الذهاب بعيدا الى
هذه الدرجه
بالمثل واغلاق وسائل الاعلام فرنسيه في
روسيا ما الذي تتوقعه على هذا الصعيد
يعني واسع بهذا بهذا الشان القنوات
الاعلاميه الفرنسيه في روسيا اعتقد انها
سوف تواجه المصير نفسه الذي واجهته
في في فرنسا واعتقد ان سيقل علاقات بين
بين الطرفين ذهب الى نقطه يعني سوف تكون
العوده عنها طويله جدا وصعبه اعتقد ان
المساله اصبحت معقده بشكل كبير جدا
الباحث في العلاقات الدوليه شكرا جزيلا لك
على مشاركتك معنا
[موسيقى]
هذا العام تغيب صوره الابرز لبوتين
فالرئيس الغار في وحل الحرب الاوكرانيه لم
ينشر صوره ككل عام وهو يغتصب في مياه
جليديه عالي الصدر للاحتفال بعيد الاقطاس
الخاص بالمسيحيين الافضل
هذه الصوره التي تظهر رجولته في مواجهه
قاعده التحديات الطبيعيه تخبو اليوم وابقى
ما رصده الاعلام الغربي بعد ما اعلن
الكريملين انه لن تكون هناك صور او لقطات
للغطس الجاليدي لبوتين لكنه مارس هذا
التقليد السنوي خاصه وان الصوره لطال ما
استفزت الغرب فكما نذكر في اجتماع قمه
مجموعه السبعه العام الماضي اراد برج
جانسي رئيس وزراء بريطانيا السابق خلع
ملابسها لاظهار عضلات الغرب امام بوتين
كما قال امام عدسات الكاميرا
الله
[موسيقى]
اكبر
الاعلام السريعه
[موسيقى]
اثار لباسه مذيع سي ان ان دون لما اجادل
حيث انه ظهر بلباس لا يليق بمذيع اخبار في
قناه عريقه
كتب النقاد انه ليس بهذه الطريقه يمكن
للقناه ان تسترجع جمهورها التي بدات تفقده
منظومه هذا فوق احصاء موقع ميديا فنسيا ان
تشهد تراجعا كبيرا في عدد متابعها في
اوقات الذروه في محافظه فوكس نيوز على
اعلى مشاهده بين الامريكيين بنسبن تخطط
المليونير شخص
وبهذا نصل الى ختام حلقتنا لليوم موعدنا
يتجدد الاسبوع المقبل شكرا جزيلا للمتابعه
[موسيقى]